this year a grand Technicolor film about
showbiz is a favorite for Best Picture
at the Oscars yes it was well-regarded
amongst critics and audiences around the
country but it's la-la-land hands-down
the best film of the year I can't even
tell you is it good enough to beat out
films like lights that are widely
considered more daring and unique
history says yes because the Oscar
voting process favors mediocrity back in
2009 the Academy switched from a
straight popular vote to Instant Runoff
voting or preferential voting the
Academy wanted to better ensure that the
film with the broadest support won but
the other side of that coin is that bold
polarizing films get pushed to the side
at its most basic level Instant Runoff
voting involves drinking a number of
choices rather than choosing just one
then the choice with the fewest votes is
removed and in those votes for that
candidate have their votes counted
according to their second favorite
candidate then the candidate that has
the fewest votes is removed and so on it
goes all the way until a candidate has
50% plus one of the vote this applies to
both the nominations process although
that does get a little weedy
and the process of selecting a Best
Picture winner so how would Instant
Runoff voting ultimately play out in a
real-life scenario let's look at 2011
where the King's Speech beat out 127
hours the fighter black swan Winter's
Bone True Grit inceptions
Toy Story 3 the social network and The
Kids Are Alright all these films were
probably first place picks on a lot of
Dallas and dead last on others it's very
possible that's a passionate fan bases
of each of these films all had the
King's Speech ranked second or third
when their first place vote wasn't
enough to span the game their second
place votes were counted and Rhee added
to the mix ultimately allowing the
King's Speech to come from behind
because the King's Speech had the
broadest support rather than the most
passionate support it took on the prize
wow what an incredible incredible honor
the new voting system seems to favor a
certain type of film we've had the
Instant Runoff voting at the Oscars for
six years and fully half of those years
have been won by movies about the movies
and I would
The King's Speech as being sort of
adjacent to that the King's Speech is
about getting training in speech and
elocution and all things that actors
have to go through think Birdman Argo
the artist the Academy is made up of six
thousand six hundred and eighty seven
film industry professionals who probably
enjoy movies about themselves they might
not rank a film about showbiz as number
one but many might place it second or
third which is precisely where it's most
dangerous in 2005 before Instant Runoff
voting was instituted crash won Best
Picture and the Oscar goes to crash it's
at home people either despised or loved
I think we really want those movies that
inspire extreme reactions one way or the
other
sometimes the movie wins that you hate
but sometimes the movie wins that you
love it I'd rather see that than a movie
that everybody was just kind of okay
with in fact crash beat all the film
that might have easily won in today's
Instant Runoff system a period film
about entertainment
directed by Hollywood royalty George
Clooney good night and good luck
[Music]
[Music]
you
[Music]